I s great. You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York
public radio, public radio, w.
C. N. N. P. R.
Hey everyone. Jad here from
radio lab this summer, W NYC.
The station that I worked for
asked me to host a singles event.
I kid you not the singles event.
I mean the idea they had and
this didn't start with me,
is that people love public radio and they
could find love through public radio.
An interesting idea and it
made for an interesting event.
The Brooklyn Brewery in Williamsburg,
Brooklyn was kind enough to loan us
their space. It's an amazing space.
About 250 people showed up ready to mingle
and it was great to meet fans of the
show, people who love public radio and
also gave us a chance to explore the
biochemistry of love and a
typical radio lab fashion.
We thought for this podcast perhaps
we would play you a bit of that event.
[inaudible]
hello? Hello. Hello.
I salute you all for
coming tonight. I Chet.
Cheers everyone for making it out.
It's not an easy thing to come and
put yourself in, in a room full of,
of attractive strangers. And, uh, I, I,
you're all very brave for
doing this. We are so,
so excited that you've turned out.
Let me just take a quick poll the
audience to see who we've got here. Um,
how many people in this room have, uh,
have never done anything like
this ever in their lives.
Ah, thank God. I'm so glad
to know I'm not alone there.
And how many people know
Radiolab have heard the show?
I right?
My people. Yes. Okay.
So what we generally do on
radio lab is we take a big idea,
sort of a basic fact of the
human condition, like sleep.
And we ask, you know, what should
be a stupid question about it?
Like why do we sleep? It
turns out no one knows.
And so we go and we investigate that idea
in the most unusual ways we can think
of. That's kind of what we do.
Interviews, theater, whatever.
So the thought was, how can we
Radiolab a Phi, this situation right
here, given that it's not about us,
it's about you guys meeting people.
Um, getting to know one another.
We are your humble servants in that
endeavor. But, uh, we thought, well,
how could we sort of explore the issue
that has brought us all together,
which is love. What is love? Okay,
that's a question that's been, no, don't
freak out when I say love by the way.
Okay. There's no pressure.
No pressure at all.
Love is the thing that happens way
downstream many, many nights from now.
You'll fifth of just,
this is just about getting to know
one of them had a fear about this.
I was like, get a say. Love
everyone's gonna go. But no.
So we call him a bunch of people and
ask them the question, what is love?
And it turns out love is a
many sited chemicals situation.
And as I was moving
through, everyone was like,
why the hell is dopamine on
my name tag? What does that,
well, what I'm going to do right
now is I'm going to play some tape.
It explains your name tax. I
called up a guy, Neeley Tucker,
who is going to help us understand
what is love. So you guys ready?
Here's some tape. All right.
Hi,
my name is Neely talker and I'm a general
assignment writer in the style section
of the Washington Post.
Okay, so I want you to
to introduce me to the,
to the posse [inaudible] chemical
posse and let's start with dopamine.
Tell me about dopamine.
Dopamine is essentially the chemical that
makes you feel good in your brain when
you're really, truly madly in love,
get a great big surge of dopamine,
which to your brain just lights up. It's
something that feels really terrific.
What does that mean though?
Like when you see that special
someone's face and you think
on the inside, is that just dopamine
searching and slashing around
that? Is Dopamine just
bouncing like, you know,
like a ball through a pinball machine?
[inaudible] yeah.
What we're talking about here is
the truly passionate form of love,
that real euphoria,
God's great free gift that's available
to everybody regardless of class, income,
race, religion. That's more of the
feeling that, that we're talking about
dopamine. Who here is dopamine?
Dopamine now you, you are the reason
we are all here tonight. Dopamine,
you are the reason for all the
sugary pop songs on the radio.
You are, no, no, I don't, I
don't mean that in a bad way.
You are the reason for all the overheated
love poetry that's ever been written,
dopamine it is, is the
quintessential love chemical.
It's a very powerful substance.
And if you don't believe me,
just to underline the point
about the power of dopamine,
I want to play the next clip
from a scientist, Helen Fisher,
whose research Neely Tucker was just
drawing upon when he described opening.
She talks about her methodology to a
conference that we recorded recently.
I'll play you just this clip just to make
it clear on how powerful dopamine is.
What I am my colleagues did was put,
I'm 32 people who are madly in love
into a functional MRI brain scanner, a
17 who were madly in love and the love
was excepted and 15 who were madly in
love and they had just been dumped. So,
uh, we, we scanned their brains, uh,
looking at a photograph
of their sweetheart and we
found activity and a lot of
brain regions. In fact,
one of the most important was a
brain region that becomes active, um,
when you feel the rush of cocaine.
So when you do cocaine,
which I know you all do,
I can see it on your faces
and when you are in love,
the same little gang of neurons in
your head get excited and squared out
dopamine. So when you, when
people say love is a drug,
it is literally true. So dopa bead,
raise your hands again one more time.
You are the engine of love and you,
you carry a particular importance
in tonight's proceedings.
However, and this brings
us to our second chemical.
Dopamine on its own is useless. Okay?
That's it. Hey,
why else would we have brought you
all together and divided you up?
Chemical number two, who here
is nor epinephrin or Epinephrin?
Let me introduce you to nor epinephrine.
All right, so introduce
me to no epinephrin.
Norepinephrine is a neuro
transmitter. It goes between, um,
and neurons in your brain,
which is a tiny little gap and it's
what communicates good feelings back and
forth. And the faster it goes,
the better you're going to feel.
It's another tiny little surge that
goes through and really leads to very
focused thought attention
and how, how exactly is that
different than dopamine?
Dopamine is a good time,
par dopamine sets up the party and get
you to having a good time in nor burn
effort is the thing that, that, uh,
makes you ask the good looking blonde
over there. If she had, you know,
I dropped by your place later,
listen to a little van Marzano,
have a glass of water.
And so, so, so, so that is
that you might have at say like
a a bar or a single sit up.
Let's say when you're in a room full
of people and you're primed and you're,
you're,
you're excited and you want to meet
someone and then you lock eyes with that
person in the whole world is
kind of drifts away. Yeah.
The last part of that
sentence is norepinephrine.
The first part might be dopamine.
Yeah.
More or less as I was coming out of really
focusing in on one particular thing,
true passion and almost the physical
sense of something that you want to take
care of right now.
It was related to me that norm for
Nevin was more like infatuation.
All right, so nor epinephrin.
I don't know if you guys heard that
subtle distinction between norepinephrine
and dopamine, but dopamine
puts you in the mood,
but it's a generalized feeling.
It's a kind of diffuse mood,
nor Epinephrin is the thing that focuses
that mood on one person in one place.
It's the thing that literally makes your
heart pound. It makes your skin sweat,
your hands get clammy, your
weak, your knees get weak.
It is the thing that actually
is the physical aspect of
attraction without which
dopamine would be useless. So nor
epinephrin raise your hands again.
[inaudible]
when you lock eyes with
that special dopamine,
someone realize that you are working
together to get the conversation started
chemically. One cannot exist
without the other. However,
and this brings us to our third and
perhaps most important chemical.
It turns out that you, you,
it turns out that there is a fatal
flaw with dopamine and nor Epinephrin
[inaudible]
in that dopamine and norepinephrine
come on strong and they fade quickly.
I know, I know.
However,
there is a third chemical that comes
online that carries you through into that
relationship and into kids and all
that. I know, I know. No, no, no,
no pressure, no pressure, no pressure.
So let me play you an introduction
to that third chemical.
Who's Oxytocin in here? Alright,
oxytocin. Listen Up.
All right, so we got a dopamine.
We got Nora of an Efrin,
both of which are good for quick highs,
but then there's the thing that we all
know happens after you've been with a
person for six months, maybe longer. Yeah.
It doesn't always have to be so cynical,
but you just, you know, the, the,
the fire in your loins, uh,
abs a little bit and, and,
and you feel something else.
What is that chemical that
that is that comes online
that's actually Towson.
Oh, [inaudible].
It's a long lasting chemical
in your brain that can,
can continue to flow
without frying your brain.
If you constantly had surges
of dopamine and Norepinephrine,
it would drive you nuts.
What kicks in is Oxytocin,
which doesn't have the same highs,
but it's a much more
sustainable way to live.
And what emotion or state of mind
would you associate with oxytocin?
Answer more of, of peace and stability
in a less intense form of, of,
of happiness or content. There we go.
Could we call it companionship
or something like
the longterm are lifelong
commitment that two people share,
that they care for each other in good
times or in bad. And they are really,
they're from one another, which
encompasses friendship, companionship,
and at the end of things, uh, love.
That's sort of what sustains us all.
Oxy.
All right, so just to do
a quick recap, we've have,
we have dopamine which goes by
its street name of romantic love.
That's dopamine. And then we
have norepinephrine Epinephrin,
which can be called different
things. Infatuation.
Perhaps it's the physical
aspects of attraction
or lust as some people in the front said.
And then we have the last camel would
come online, which we'll call attachment c
no, in order to have a lasting, true love,
you need all three
chemicals, people, all three.
A chemical Manajatwa is what's in order.
So that's the,
that brings us to our game
today or activity as it's
called your task right now
is to go and find people of
different chemical persuasions.
Okay. Check their name tag. You
want one of each one, oxytocin,
one dopamine, one norepinephrine.
You've got some conversation
starters on the card, go with it.
If it works or no, doesn't matter.
And then the mingling
started. It did not stop.
So we ended up cutting out
the rest of our programs
cause everyone was having such a
good time. But we do have it for you.
Hear a story told by Helen Fisher about
what can happen when you try to take the
chemicals of love into your own hands.
She told the story of the
Ted Conference in 2006.
I want to tell you a story about the
culture of love, the magic of it.
It was a graduate student and a,
this graduate student was madly in love
with another graduate student and um,
she was not in love with him and they
were all at a conference in Beijing and he
knew from our work that um,
if you go and do something
very novel with somebody,
you can drive up the dopamine in the
brain and perhaps triggered this brain
system for romantic love.
So he decided he'd put
science to work and uh,
he invited this girl to go off
on a rickshaw ride with him.
And sure enough, I've never been in one,
but apparently they go all around the
buses and the trucks and it's crazy and
it's noisy and it's exciting.
And he figured this would drive up the
dove of man and she'd fall in love with
them.
So off they go and she's squealing and
squeezing him and laughing and having a
wonderful time and are related.
They get down off of the
rickshaw them and um,
she throws her hands up and she says,
wasn't that wonderful and
wasn't there rickshaw driver,
handsome
[inaudible].
All right, now we'll leave
you with the following story.
And this is one of the most
romantic stories that I know of.
We aired it a few years back for
program that we produced on space.
Carl Sagan as in the Carl
Sagan of billions and billions,
that cross thing.
And in 1977 was asked by NASA to compile
essentially a mix tape of the human
experience. They asked them to
basically go out into the world record.
All of the sounds that reflect
human life on this planet.
Put it onto a gold record,
put the record into a capsule,
shoot the capsule into space so that
many millions of years from now,
perhaps some alien will
run across the capsule,
somehow play the record and learn
about us. That was the idea.
And so Carl Sagan appointed Annie drew
alion as the leader of the team that
would choose those sounds.
And I spoke with Annie many years ago
about the process that she went through to
choose those sounds. My visited
her upstate at, at her home,
and we sat in the backyard
near a waterfall. That's
the sound that you'll hear.
And she described how
she chose the sounds.
My name is Danny Durian and it was
honored to be the creative director of the
voyager interstellar messaged project,
which began in early 1977 but
now how does this come about?
I think about the project now and
it's so exciting to think about,
I mean, it's such a romantic idea. Did
you know that at the time? Absolutely.
We felt first of all that this was a
kind of sacred trust that here we were
habit as a very flawed
human beings with a huge,
a huge holes in our knowledge
of all of these subjects.
Building a cultural Noah's Ark.
It was a chance to tell something of
what life on earth was like to beings of
perhaps a thousand million
years from now because the,
the voyager engineers were saying this
record will have a shelf life of a
billion years. That didn't
raise goosebumps then you'd
have to be made of wood.
A, it was also the, the, the,
the season that Carl Sagan and I fell so
madly in love with each other and here
we were taking on this mythic challenge
and knowing that before it was done,
two spacecraft would lift off from the
planet earth moving at an average speed
of 35,000 miles an hour for the
next thousand million years.
And on it we'd be a kiss,
a mother's first word.
Oh come on now.
[inaudible]
greetings in the 59 most
populous human languages, shallow
Darcel Hellos, children of planet earth
as well as one non human language,
the readings of the humpback
whales.
And it was a sacred undertaking because
it was saying we want to be citizens of
the cosmos. They want
you to know about that.
[inaudible]
tell me about the moment you
fell in love with Carl Sagan.
You said it was during the
voyager compilation? Yes, it was.
It was on June 1st,
1977 I had been looking for some time
for that piece of Chinese music that we
could put on the voyager record and not
feel like idiots for having done so.
And um,
I was very excited because I'd finally
found a ethnomusicologist composer at
Columbia University who told me without
a moment's hesitation that this peace
flowing streams,
which was represented to me as one of
the oldest pieces of Chinese music,
2,500 years old. Oh, was the
piece we should put on the record.
So I called Carl who was traveling,
he was in Tucson, Arizona giving a talk.
And we had been alone many times during
the making of the record and his friends
for three years.
And neither of us had ever said anything
to the other. We were both involved,
Baba people. We'd had these
wonderful storing conversations,
but we had both been completely just
professional about everything and his
friends. And he wasn't
there. Left a message.
Hour later phone rings,
pick up the phone and I hear
this wonderful voice and he said,
I get back to my hotel room and I find
this message and it says any card.
And I say to myself, why didn't you
leave me this message 10 years ago?
And my heart completely skipped a beat.
I can still remember it so perfectly.
And I said, for keeps. And he
said, you mean get married?
And I said yes. And we had never
kissed. We had never, you know,
even had any kind of
personal discussion before.
We both hung up the phone
and I just screamed out loud.
I remember it so well cause it
was this great Eureka moment.
It was just like a scientific discovery
and then the phone rang and I was
thinking, Oh shit, you know, like, and a
phone rang and it was Carl and he said,
I just wanted to make sure that that
really happened. We're getting married,
right? And I said, yeah, we're
getting married. He said, okay,
just in the making sure. And um,
spacecraft lifted off on
August 20th and August 22nd,
we told everyone involved and we were
together from that moment until his death
in 1996 and December. Wow.
Talk about Romantic Micah magic.
And part of my feeling about
voyager obviously and part
of what I was feeling in
the recording of my
brainwaves, my heart, my eyes,
everything in that
meditation on the record,
I had asked Carl whether or not would
be possible to compress the impulses in
one's brain and nervous system into sound
and then put that sound on the record
and then think that perhaps
the extraterrestrials of
the future would be able to
reconstitute that data into thought.
And he looked at me and beautiful
May Day in New York City and said,
well, you know, now is a million
years is a long time. You know,
why don't you go do it?
Because who knows? You know,
who knows what's possible
in a thousand million years.
And so my brain waves and rem,
every little sound that my body was making
was recorded at Bellevue Hospital in
New York.
This was two days after Carla and
I declared our love for each other.
And so what I often think is that
maybe a hundred million years from now,
he knows somebody flags that
record down. And I always wonder,
because part of what I was thinking in
this meditation was about the wonder of
love and of being in love and to
know it's on those two spacecraft.
Even now in my, whenever I'm
down, you know, I'm thinking,
and still they move 35,000 miles an hour,
leaving our solar system for the
great wide open c interstellar space.